[Aplausos]
de un día para otro tierra este empleo
en el 2020 en eeuu se perdieron
para méxico fueron más de 12 millones en
colombia 3 extrañamente en guatemala
cuentan con un 2.5 por ciento de índices
de desempleo muy similar al de suecia
tienes un plan si te toca a ti
el problema el desempleo no es que los
gobiernos lo miran mal es un tema tabú
para la sociedad no se habla con la
familia con los amigos en la sobremesa
con los hijos inclusive con la pareja es
complicado ellos también viven su parte
de la historia pero por qué no hablar
del tema
enfrentar el desempleo es un recorrido
solitario
a pesar de que puedas encontrar apoyo en
el camino nadie sabe cuánto pesa tu
mochila
si metemos a una bolsa
tus deudas
tus gastos
la presión
el hecho de que tus ahorros van
perdiéndose todo esto pesan
es como un mal sueño
imaginativas en un carro a toda
velocidad tú vas en el asiento trasero
tiene sientes esta desesperación por
pasarte al
a tomar el volante y tomar el control de
las cosas si no puedes
es un tema que no discrimina
no importa la edad no importa el género
tus preferencias
puede ser en un solo sector o puede ser
una pandemia global la crisis global
cuando era el recién ingresado
puede tomar té meses en conseguir en tu
primer empleo
yo recuerdo que la frase que más se
escuchaba es no tienes experiencia
para otros podría ser
está sobre calificado pero no tiene
sentido es la principal razón para
seguir que preparando
algunos especialistas dicen que el mejor
momento para
encontrar trabajo es cuando tienes
trabajo eso te permite a no tomar
decisiones apresuradas o compresión
te deja elegir cuál es el siguiente paso
en tu carrera
buscar trabajo es un trabajo de tiempo
completo
un empleado llega a su casa llega
en donde se puede desconectar el doctor
ingeniero
para desempleados
no hay un momento en el día en donde no
sientas esa presión
esa voz en tu cabeza preguntando camps
hacer sigues los consejos más comunes
tienes un currículum en inglés en
español con un diseño distinto pdf word
con fotos sin fotos y aún no sabe
puedes pasar horas en bolsas de trabajo
en redes sociales enviando currículums
por correo electrónico
el tiempo puede pasar tan lento y tan
rápido a la vez
sobre todo cuando no tienes un plan
te puedes sentir perdido
ahora imagina un lugar en donde si
puedes hablar de este tema hace unos
años salí de una relación laboral y como
cualquier otra persona me puse a buscar
oportunidades
en ese ir y venir de entrevistas y
llamadas y silencios conocí gente
la misma situación y decidimos adoptar
nos empezamos a compartir contenido
vacantes artículos pero la dinámica se
empezó a complicar en el inc y creé un
grupo llamado el blog del desempleo
seguimos compartiendo contenido se pasó
la voz la dinámica original se conserva
y la invitación también era para
headhunters y reclutadores no sólo por
las vacantes que podrían tener activas
en sus empresas pero
por los consejos que les pedíamos que
compartieran con la comunidad
de 10 en 10 paso a cientos ahora miles
de bien
y todos conservan la dinámica original
tienes que llegar compartiendo contenido
antes de pedir ayuda
las reglas del grupo son simples
respeto para todos no aceptamos spam y
no aceptamos
bastantes engañosas
puedes buscar en tu sector puedes probar
en otras industrias te topas a veces con
vacantes perfectas que podrías sentir
que tu currículo te emociones envías tu
currículum y esperas la llamada
pueden pasar horas días semanas
es un gran error apostarle solo un par
de vacantes
pero una de las elecciones más grandes
en todo este ejercicio es que lo más
importante dentro de tu currículum eres
tú
no los puestos no las marcas o las
empresas con las que has trabajado
y lo que puedes hacer por ti por la
empresa tenemos que entender que un
trabajo no nos define y si piensas así
qué pasa cuando ya no lo tienes dejas de
existir
en este grupo encontré donde tener esa
conversación
todo lo que te ha pasado lo que estás
viviendo encontrar a gente donde puedes
compartirlo y saber que ellos lo
entienden
para más allá de vacantes y artículos
cuando crees estar solo en un camino tan
rudo puedes llegar a tener una conexión
personal con toda esta gente
los mejor los mejores consejos tal vez
de cómo resolver una deuda con iván con
una tarjeta
podría no venir de un financiero sino de
alguien con una deuda más grande que la
tuya
esto es para ti
recién egresado que apenas estás
buscando oportunidades
para ti que estás buscando tu primer
gerencia de dirección
a quienes después de una pandemia les
cambió el plan y tuvieron que empezar de
cero no importa si eres empresario
emprendedor
[Música]
aún en el punto más profundo de un
fracaso tenemos la capacidad de
reinventarnos
es en esa oscuridad
en la que tenemos que aprovechar
y atrevernos a ser nosotros mismos oa
cambiar
sobre todo a confiar
encuentren su inspiración puede ser en
sus hijos familia amigos
las miles de historias en ese grupo que
han sido una fuente interminable de
inspiración para mí
lidia diurna bitch termina una de sus
pláticas diciendo tu historia merece ser
contada
y no hay nadie mejor que tú para hacerlo
esto es el bloque del desempleo y es la
historia de cómo encontré ayuda ayudando
[Aplausos]